alors du théâtre avec une pièce d'octave
mirbeau à mon avis ménagé c'est plutôt
caustique
oui je crois qu'il est d'ailleurs que
c'est pour cette raison que lorsque vous
vous aimez cet auteur mais je suis pas
sûr que vous allez forcément apprécié
l'extrait qui suit alors bon la pièce
raconte l'histoire d'un couple arrivé à
la fin de sa vie et un couple uni par la
haine qu'ils se portent l'un l'autre et
je crois deviner encore une fois c'est
la femme calme mauvais rôle a
effectivement c'est une pièce
excessivement misogyne puisque la femme
est un peu accusé d'être une
calculatrice perverse on va dire elle va
même jusqu'à pousser son mari dont les
bras de sa voisine est arrivé ici il
paraît qu'elle avait 34 mal pourquoi
dis-tu si j'ai trois sur sept on l'a
avec sa pelle ne te plaît pas à moins
grande eau eau par exemple je m'occupe
bien cette dame et son cheval il si mal
de ses 34 mal pourquoi te cacher des
mois à voyons tu sais bien que je ne
suis pas jalouse mais je vous dis pas la
tête en vérité ce gie poe petit cheval
jalouse ou non cette dame je les
rencontre et comme tout le monde sur la
route elle pas si peu intéressé était
que maintenant que ce serait de dire si
elle est blonde ou brune
grâce aux maigres relais de joli joli
très très très joli et délicieusement
blonba tant mieux pour elle